nadège bonjour alors il ya du monde
autour de vous peut-être aussi des
petites tensions le voit juste derrière
vous quelle est la situation
[Musique]
mais alors comment par les radios depuis
hier on a dépassé la place de la bourse
depuis quelques heures maintenant
une manifestation qui a commencé dans le
calme et la bonne humeur et qui a
dégénéré il y à peu près un quart
d'heure pourquoi parce que un des
manifestants d'autres manifestations et
bien ont intégré ce cortège et la
situation a donc dérapé des heurts ont
éclaté entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre vous le voyez du mobilier urbain
des poubelles ont été incendiées donc
beaucoup de tensions ici sur cette
avenue de villiers le cortège n avance
plus dorénavant le périmètre est
complètement bouclé par les forces de
l'ordre
donc on voit là une manifestation qui
avait bien commencé et qui a dégénéré
on va en parler avec linda bigot inda
bigot qui est l'organisatrice de cette
manifestation et qui est extrêmement
déçu de la tournure des événements une
manifestation qui se voulait pacifique
avec toujours les mêmes revendications
pour les j les jeunes plus de pouvoir
d'achat la mise en place du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et puis une
demande pour plus de justice fiscale et
sociale et environnementale inda bigot
bonjour alors racontez nous cette
manifestation elle a bien commencé place
de la bourse
le cortège avançait de manière pacifique
dans la bonne humeur
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait tout
se passe bien jusqu'à présent il n'y a
pas de problème donc j'ai pas trop
compris ce qui s'est passé avec la
manifestation qui était déclarée à place
wagram
à part acquise que si tu sais pas c'est
qu'ils ont rejoint le cortège
d'après ce que je comprends je suis
comme vous je suis un peu dans le flou
j'arrive pas à voir les informations
donc bon après on s'ils veulent venir
bien sûr qu'ils sont les bienvenus n'y a
pas de souci
mais effectivement on n'a pas compris
comment se fait-il que cortège de
l'autre côté ne soit pas parti est ce
qu'il ya eu une interdiction de
rassemblement aux dernières minutes on
n'a pas d'information après on est tous
citoyens tous en colère si on peut tous
se rejoindre pourquoi pas y'a pas de
soucis qui a eu des coups de matraques
et du gaz lacrymogène ont pas d incendie
des deux poubelles lac éclate on sent
que c'est pas la même manifestation à
laquelle on assiste maintenant vous êtes
déçu de la tournure de cette journée pas
du tout la journée n'est pas finie 1 ce
sont des quoi qu'il arrive généralement
dans toutes les manifestations qu'elles
soient gilet jaune citoyenne syndicales
ou autre c'est ce bon voilà c'est pas
des exceptions
après que voulez vous je vous dise la
manifestation n'est toujours pas finie
et des n'a pas encore été déclaré
interdit
on n'a pas demandé de disperser pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de
d'affrontements cette principale
je pense qu'on va y en a eu quelques-uns
tout à l'heure des affrontements des
coups de matraques et des
interpellations beaucoup
d'interpellations d'accord j'ai pas vu
effectivement parce que comme voilà je
suis de cortège est quand même assez
gros et assez grand je peux pas être
partout
donc c'est vous qui me l'apprenez c'est
malheureux c'est malheureux une
manifestation qui commençait bien
jusqu'à maintenant elle est toujours
aussi bien ce jour ce sont juste des
exceptions donc après on va pas en faire
tout un drame satisfaits de l'affluence
de ce 12 septembre on s'attendait à ce
que le mouvement renaisse de ses cendres
qu'en est il veut plutôt satisfait tous
pas seulement pour moi je suis satisfait
d'une choses et qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya
pas que de gilet jaune
gd yade et du personnel soignant qui est
ici des pompiers en civil
vous avez des vtc qui sont là des
enseignants qui sont là des personnes de
la ratp dont un syndicaliste nous avons
aussi les jeunes de les jeunes étudiants
qui sont là donc c'est vraiment une
manif citoyenne comme ce que je
prévoyais cette semaine en particulier à
une confrontation à écrans différents
j'ai envie de dire entre vous et jérôme
rodriguez qui est l'autre leader de ce
mouvement est ce que cette division est
elle participe à un petit peu justement
l essoufflement de ce mouvement est ce
que cette division elles sont vraiment
utiles ou au mouvement
écoutez nez
moi je ne parle pas de division parce
que ne divise que celui qui veut je suis
pour le rassemblement
ça c'est un fait nous avons des avis
divergent complètement certains aspirent
à peut-être à des carrières politiques
moi pas donc je suis organisatrice de
manifestations
ça fait plus d'un an que j'organise pour
les citoyens en fonction de leurs
demandes de leurs revendications
je n'aspire absolument pas à créer deux
partis politiques ou manipuler la colère
des gens pour pouvoir créer un parti
politique
aujourd'hui les gens veulent être en
masse dans la rue faire plier ce
gouvernement concernant leurs exigences
à former une seule masse gigantesque en
rassemblant toutes les luttes je pense
que c'est le véritable pouvoir du pape
il est dans la rue il est arrivé jérôme
rodriguez on l'a aperçu tout à l'heure
il est toujours le bienvenu au sein de
cette manifestation
elle va demander ça aux gens qui sont
dans la manifestation les avis sont
mitigés et partager
les avis sont mitigés partager moi bon
je lui ai expliqué mon sentiment
voilà parce que quand on appelle à la
désobéissance civile la moindre des
choses est de tenir ses engagements
jusqu'au bout là je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui ne sont pas
contents de sa présence interrompt vous
pouvez pas nous dire qu'il n'ya pas deux
heures et que cette manifestation se
déroule dans le calme et la bonne humeur
non on a du gaz lacrymogène on a des
gens qui courent partout en oeuvre des
forces de l'ordre ceux qui sont sur le
qui-vive ça ouais c'est pas une
manifestation qui se déroule bien à
écouter de toute façon comme je vous dis
a toujours des petits couacs mais
regardez les gens repartent
c'est le principal en cas pas de blessés
c'est le principal là la manifestation
repas